I think it's obvious that's a hard we
can't stay as Tory party chair the very
idea that he can be discussing and
negotiating his own tax affairs with the
body that he's supposed to be running
now everybody knows it's wrong he
clearly isn't going to resign and so the
Prime Minister needs to show some
leadership this is a test of the Prime
Minister he promised us his first words
integrity and accountability well if
those words mean anything the Prime
Minister should sack him and Sack him
today and show some leadership because
if he doesn't it's just going to be
further Evidence I think for the relief
public as to just how weak this prime
minister really is where's this going to
end though I mean a labor and I was
saying that top politicians should
release their tax returns I mean is that
something you'd expect the shuttle
cabinet to do for example well look I
mean the issue is not whether zahawi is
releasing his tax returns to the public
the issue is whether they were accurate
when he filled them in
beginning to see the answer to that
question so this is all about
what was actually in his returns the
promise knows this the Prime Minister
knows that his position as as chair of
the party is untenable the Prime
Minister promised us integrity and
accountability he needs to show some
leadership and Sack him and if he
doesn't then that in my view is a strong
failure of leadership just quickly you
could ask an urgent question on this in
Parliament today well Olympic Parliament
procedures um today no doubt but um you
know this is really a question for the
Prime Minister you know what I would say
to the prime minister is show some
leadership if this was somebody in my
team I would sack them this is really
now much more a question for the Prime
Minister than anybody else on this issue
okay just two final questions first of
all on another chairman that is of the
BBC again another investigation taking
place today are you are you saying that
how the chairman of the BBC is appointed
should not be taken out of the hands of
the Prime Minister well there's clearly
serious questions to answer here aren't
there in terms of the connect action the
discussions and what went on it's right
that it's being looked at and we need to
get to the bottom of this as quickly as
possible but I think for many people
this morning who are struggling with
their bills struggling with their jobs
struggling with all of the pressures
that come about because of 13 years of
failure they'll be looking at a
government saying what do we got we've
got Scandal story after Scandal story
what they want is a government that's
delivering and they haven't got that